Fans of the CW's Batwoman will be disappointed
to learn that Ruby Rose has unexpectedly bowed
out of the title role of Kate Kane.
The parting from the show appears to be perfectly
amicable, as Rose's announcement includes
a long thank you to her director and producers
for the opportunity.
Nonetheless, she seems to feel walking away
is best for her future.
It's not as though the show has performed
poorly Batwoman's premiere season punched
in a comparable weight class to more established
shows in the cable network's Arrowverse lineup,
ending up as the network's third-most watched
program of 2019.
The news of the lead actor's departure is
surprising and even upsetting, but it's not
all bad.
With the recent announcement from the CW that
the network plans to delay virtually all new
season premieres until at least January 2021,
Batwoman's producers will have plenty of extra
time to seek out a new lead.
Lending further comfort, the press release
confirming Rose's departure additionally included
a reassurance that the channel is still dedicated
to finding another LGBTQ actress to fill the
role of the canonically lesbian hero.
But why did Ruby Rose exit the role so suddenly,
when everything seems to be going just the
way any television actor would want?
Well, there are a number of possible reasons.
"I'm not asking you to be a hero.
I'm just asking you to keep going."
Back in the summer of 2019, Rose had to have
emergency surgery due to herniated discs in
her spine that threatened to paralyze her.
"This is your spine.
Two of your discs have herniated, and they've
broken all the protective layers.
You have, like, this tiny amount that your
spine is, like, not severed…"
The injury was sustained at some point during
the filming of Batwoman's first season, and
over time as Rose began to experience numbness
in her extremities, realization set in that
the injury might be much more serious than
at first believed.
She didn't reveal this fact until that September,
well after the surgery, and as far as anyone
is publicly aware, she has indeed recovered
just fine from her injury.
Variety reports an anonymous source that claims
Rose departing the role has nothing to do
with her health, but it's difficult to say
exactly what that means.
She's probably perfectly healthy now, since
doctors intervened before the injury could
become permanent, but it may have affected
her strength and flexibility in a way that
prevented her from fully recovering in time
for filming.
It's not necessarily that she's unhealthy,
but there could be uncertainty around how
safe it is to continue performing such a stunt-heavy
role after a spine injury, even a healed one.
It's also entirely possible that the injury
has simply brought Rose to second-guess her
dedication to the role.
Anyone would question how willing they are
to continue working a job after getting so
seriously hurt on-site, even when there's
no one at fault.
The aforementioned network-wide delay of new
content on the CW, alternatively, may have
provided Rose an opportunity she may have
been looking for.
In an interview with Glamour in September
2019, shortly before the revelation of her
spinal injury, Rose confessed to feeling homesick
for her native Australia, and that she had
an interest in pursuing future roles closer
to home.
Television work in America necessitates keeping
a part-time home in LA and living there at
least during the filming season, though it's
beneficial to remain during all the required
press tours as well.
When you consider that TV pre-production and
filming can take up almost half the year on
its own and that Australia is thousands of
miles away, it would be extraordinarily difficult
to spend much time back in Australia while
playing a principal role in a sprawling superhero
television franchise like the Arrowverse.
She has also been open about past struggles
with her mental health, so it's understandable
that being closer to home might help her feel
more grounded.
Whatever the reason for Rose's departure,
she's entirely allowed to walk away, especially
in circumstances so unprecedented that a whole
television network has shifted its release
schedule.
Rose has no publicly-announced project that
she's gravitating towards instead not that
she would need to have one to justify her
decision.
Wherever she shows up next, we'll certainly
be excited to see her again.
"I will protect my city."
"No, you won't.
Because you're done.
Get out."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.